c'est ainsi que quan ne nous dit pas
adieu mais un au revoir
entouré de tous ses proches et des gens
qu'il aime notre adolescence a vraiment
été à trop si on va faire ce qu'on
aurait dû faire depuis 15 ans une
révolution je veux que vous vous rendiez
à la réunion des anciens élèves et vous
balancier mais se rendre sur si sale con
je vous filmez vous partagiez je veux
que le monde sache qu'il faut qu'une
telle chi l'ha union tallinn dans deux
semaines on a quoi 30 followers à nous
trois réunis c'est pour ça qu'on va
avoir besoin d'être quelqu'un qui est
dans le guen un proche même de notre
famille assez votre frère fait quoi
c'est une douce de télé réalité où ils
sont beaux ils ont au square n'a qu'à
demander à ton frère
vous avez des looks de merde vous êtes
normaux vous êtes chiant on va vous
trouver des personnalités de cette
agréable
t'es sûr vous êtes parfait d'accord des
gens qui aiment le cirque ont bien c'est
comme le plastique après à sortir vos
butin sans prévenir les vosgiens ballon
scénario ça quelque chose avait foutu
[Musique]
ces métaphores bordel [ __ ] tu allais
vraiment senti un tamis semeta forcément
viens viens j'y terre flamand